petit questionnaire entre amis dont que
cherchent les américains en écoutant
leurs alliés de leur côté les européens
ont-ils les moyens de se défendre c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage ce soir pour
en parler nous sommes avec eux pierre
martinet un ancien agent du service
action de la dgse bonsoir à pierre
martinet merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés françois chauvancy général de
brigade expert en géostratégie bonsoir
général chauvancy merci d'être avec nous
à tous les deux donc une première
affaire en révéler en 2013 le pendant de
cette affaire en plusieurs personnalités
politiques européennes de premier plan
écouter très attentivement manifestement
entre 2012 et 2014 par l' agence de
renseignement américaine
françois chauveau six questions naïves
et bêtement fins et norman d'espionner
ses amis je pense qu'il y à deux
dimensions
la première a les politiques comment
accepter qu'un allié écoute son allié
par des bois d'espionnage la deuxième
est pragmatique
comment se faire effacer finalement
l'illusion que on aimerait bien ce que
savoir ce que portent nos alliés il n'y
a rien que de plus naturel de entre
guillemets pragmatiquement et non pas
politiquement de chercher à savoir ce
que pensent ses alliés maintenant tout
le reportage que vous êtes montrés
montre bien d'abord que curieusement sa
commande et une administration démocrate
qui a voulu espionner quand même ses
alliés
quand on voit le débat aux états unis
sur les démocrates et les républicains
on peut quand même s'interroger
et puis dernier point quand même c'est
que quand même ne faisons pas
d'illusions savoir ce que pense l'autre
qui soit un adversaire un ennemi ou un
allié c'est une partie du renseignement
maintenant le mot confiance et à moins
important je crois que vous l'avez
souligné
reportage avec angela merkel on doit
avoir confiance dans ses alliés et si
ses alliés vous espionne comment peut-on
avoir confiance en dieu
pierre martin et là on apprend quand
même 1 par rapport à 2013 et les
premières révélations on apprend quand
même que là il s'agit d'une espionnage
de grande ampleur avec des câbles
télécom alors je suis pas spécialiste en
la matière vous allez mieux pour nous
l'expliquer et avec une complicité d'un
ami européen a priori le danemark un
rasta établir évidemment la preuve que
le gouvernement le le savait mais quand
même ça fait la différence non
alors l'année ça a été a été créé pour
respirer espionner le reste le reste du
monde donc pour moi du tout étonné que
qu'on découvre un nouveau cas est laissé
à espionner en europe
vous espérez vos amis vous en général on
se concentre sur les ions mais non là
alors il faut utiliser ben alors il ya
espionner et avoir avoir un peu de
l'information c'est pour moi c'est deux
choses différentes parce que dans six si
on emploie le terme espionnage a une
connotation un peu plus guerrière que
quelques que avoir du renseignement il y
avait relevé une phrase d'un des
conseillers à la sécurité nationale du
jimmy carter qui disait sur le ton de
l'humour bien évidemment il faut bien
qu'on écoute nos amis nos alliés pour
vérifier qu'ils sont toujours nos amis
donc il y a deux aspects dans cette dans
cette affaire enfin je veux dire pour
moi honnêtement pour moi ce n'est pas
une affaire c'est un non événement il y
à la gare économique est une vraie
guerre économique qui fait plus de morts
que les guerres conventionnelles tout le
monde est en haut de cette pyramide il
ya les états unis à la chine le prouve
que les chinoises font la même chose que
les américains et il est très important
pour les américains d'avoir de
l'information en europe parce que les
chinois où l'europe est aussi l e
on va dire le terrain guerre économique
des jeux des chinois donc je pense que
c'est en moi c'est un billard à trois
bandes de la part des états unis
mais dans le monde du renseignement il
ya une phrase que l'on peut tout le
temps c'est la nécessité de savoir la
nécessité de connaître c'est très
important de savoir ce que pensent nos
amis encore peut-être plus que pensent
nos ennemis alors sur moi enfin ça c'est
peut-être par naïveté ce soir je dirais
que avec nos amis ça n'irait pas plus
loin qu'une avoir de l'information sans
forcément l'utiliser ou l'utiliser de
façon économique parce que encore une
fois la guerre économique fait rage dans
le monde et ça va encore ça va encore
être le plus le cav après après le
phénomène qu vide
donc pour répondre concrètement à votre
question il n'y a rien d'étonnant il ya
certains français qui en étonne mais la
russie là la chine israël le font
également alors il ya une alliance
ah ouais mais pardonnez moi car martine
aimé mais là je vais réagir faire
ingérer aussi françois chauve en ciment
vacances et la russie on est bien placé
sur cette scène pour le savoir c'est
l'écrit dans fait c'est un coup de
sanctions enfin bref voilà c'était les
grands méchants en france et les états
unis bon là on sait pas bien d'espionner
ses noms mais elle a franchement je suis
un peu partout donc pour une fois mais
en face c'est tellement flagrant mais je
suis d'accord avec vous je suis d'accord
avec vous mais je partage votre opinion
c'est absolument fin pour moi c'est la
même chose
je suis d'accord avec vous il n'ya que
c'est encore une fois je je j'abonde
dans votre sens il n'y a qu'en europe
qu'on s'étonne que les américains
espionnent alors franchement ça va pas
aller bien loin il va y avoir peut-être
une convocation d'un ambassadeur et
encore 2
de numéro trois du nombre sade mais ça
s'arrêtera là parce que c'est pas la
première fois que ça arrive je me
souviens avoir fait un article là dessus
il ya quelques années au moment de la
grippe du premier espionnage de
l'allemagne bon voilà ça n'a rien donné
ça ne donnera rien et il est important
qu'on ait des informations encore une
fois l'information d'abord de
l'information c'est bien mais savoir ce
qu'on en fait c'est c'est une chose
différente 1,6 et de la formation pour
faire de l'offensif sur nos amis ok mais
si c'est de la formation pourra voir
comment on dirait quand vous avez de la
formation c'est comme aux échecs c'est
un coup d'avancé je suis désolé non mais
dans le monde économique dans le monde
de l'entreprise
alors on sait pas si c'est du cinéma où
l'on met enfin emmanuel macron avait pas
l'air de prendre
voilà aussi bien que vous le décrivez
avec un gala merkel on les a entendu
tout à l'heure dans la lignée quelques
heures plus tôt fonds repose d'écouter
le secrétaire d'état chargé aux affaires
européennes clément bonne entre alliés
il doit y avoir une confiance une
coopération minimale donc ses effets
potentiels sont graves
il faut les vérifier et ensuite en tirer
des conséquences en terme de coopération
françois chavance y faire martin et
voilà un relativisme enfin quand même
ils ont pas l'air de tellement bien le
coup on est on peut les comprendre il
faudra en tirer les conséquences
à quoi doit-on s'attendre si ces faits
sont établis
oui enfin je pense que je rejoins une
partie de l'argumentation qui a été
avancé par un martinez dis simplement
que martinez pardon dit simplement que
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure il ya une
relation politique et il ya une relation
pragmatique je dit pas autre chose
politique comment voulez vous que nous
gouvernement ne dise pas le ne condamne
pas cette situation
ancien ne leur aplomb pas sous un
gouvernement démocrate aux états unis
donc on ne peut pas ne pas réagir et ne
pas dire ce n'est pas bien
maintenant il ya une réalité qu'elle
soit économique dont je ne partage pas
uniquement le point de vue économique
mais il est aussi politique il est aussi
relations internationales en général ce
sont des rapports de force ou doit
savoir ce que les autres pensent et
c'est vrai que nos alliés n'ont pas
toujours prouvé dans le passé qu'ils
étaient de forcément d
alliez vous avez aussi leur propre
agenda comme tout état il ya des agendas
nationaux
maintenant je rebondirai ce que vous
avez dit à quelques instants sur
effectivement cruellement cette
disproportion entre accusé la russie
d'un côté et ne pas accuser des états
unis oui les etats unis doivent montrer
qu' on peut leur faire confiance et que
l'attitude qu'ils ont eues il y a
quelques années doit bien être
on doit bien prouvé aujourd'hui que ce
n'est sa n'a plus lieu quand on relit
les articles concernant l'administration
obama et ils vont très bien on va
arrêter on va se calmer bon fou rire
effet que c'est vrai effectivement avec
l'administration joe biden aujourd'hui
qui a été quand même parfaitement au
contact d'obama c'est la moindre des
choses
il pourrait au moins confirmé qu'il n'ya
plus d'actes je dirais je reprends le
mot espionnage tellement plus simple
pour le commun des mortels vis-à-vis de
ses alliés je pense que la nuit sera son
maiden doit tout à fait confirmé que la
et nsa n'écoute plus ses alliés car ce
que vous avez évoqué il ya quelques
instants quand sur le mot confiance
on ne peut pas développer la notion de
confiance entre alliés si des alliés
espionne les autres donc en l'occurrence
il ya un soupçon d'espionnage
il est normal que les politiques
français allemands et autres disent ça
ne peut pas continuer et il est temps
que joe biden dans ce cas là disent bien
oui non à une hélice à n'espionne plus
les dirigeants européens et alliés
depuis 4 5 ans voilà nous sommes dans la
politique nous sommes pas dans la
pratique du renseignement donc je
comprends tout à fait dans la pratique
du renseignement peut-être qu'il y aura
des des entorses
maintenant il ya un point qui n'a pas
été relevé le point qui n'a pas été
relevé je suis très surpris d'entendre
dire que le services secrets danois ont
participé à cette action j'allais refuse
évidemment parce que c'est ce qui retire
la tension dans cette affaire et ce qui
n'avait pas été relevé en 2013 alors on
sait pas si le gouvernement est au
courant c'est pas et habib enfin en tout
cas que les services secrets danois et
aider ça ça semble à peu près en tout
cas c'était les révélations de ce
week-end c'est très étonnant n'est ce
pas je devrais je n'avais plus c'est
inadmissible il ya un devoir de loyauté
envers son gouvernement envers ces
politiques est un service de
seulement qu'ils travailleraient entre
guillemets dans le domaine de
l'espionnage au profit d'une nation
étrangère
moi ça m'interpelle j'appelle presque ça
de la trahison pour pas utiliser un
terme trop fort mais quand même c'est
une forme de trahison
sauf si il ya eu un aval politique
donc je pense qu'il va y avoir entre
guillemets des règlements de comptes au
danemark sur ce qui aurait pu autoriser
des actions que moi je considère comme
inacceptable mais pardonnez moi mais
quel intérêt pour le danemark d'aidé
comme ça les états unis à faire
espionner les alliés je pense que c'est
pas forcément l'objectif d'en de
d'espionner les alliés simplement il ya
eu une convergence d'intérêts un moment
donné entre les services secrets danois
est là est né c'est pour dire bah tiens
après tout pourquoi pas on se connaît on
se fait confiance il n'y a pas de
répercussion sur la dir est l'union
européenne
bon je dirais qu'à la limite on pourrait
comprendre que pas alors je l'utilisé à
un thème qui n'est peut-être pas adapté
le mot copinage les les personnes du
renseignement se connaissent ils se
fréquentent
ils se rencontrent et je crois peut-être
pas eu à un échange de service mais je
ne suis pas un expert du domaine qui
simplement c'est comme ça que je
comprendrais les choses et je pense
qu'il ya eu un excès de deux confiante
la part des danois vis-à-vis de l'année
c'est qu'il faudra bien expliquer
pourquoi il ya eu cette collusion
là par contre terme est fort c'est une
collusion entre les services secrets
danois donc d'un état souverain avec les
états unis
sans forcément l'accord du pouvoir
politique et là je crois que c'est un
vrai problème qui devra être éclairci
observe martinez sur cette implication
danoise alors je partage évidemment ce
qui vient d'être dit
parce que il faut savoir alors est ce
que est ce que les câbles ont été mis à
disposition sans savoir ce qui quand ils
allaient servir réellement ou est ce que
comme dit le général
il y avait vraiment un copinage la tête
des services de renseignements danois
à pour mettre en place une vraie machine
d'espionnage qui partirait de là ils
seraient partis du danemark
si si les services de renseignement
danois ont agi seuls dans leur coin sans
avoir l'autorisation à l'ordre du
politique parce que je rappelle quand
même que tous les ministères les
services de renseignement est ce que c
est ce que c'est seulement possible de
se passer de l'autorisation du
gouvernement dans ces cas la théorie non
en théorie non moi depuis enfin j'ai
souvent lu cette question de la part des
journalistes
est-ce que vous avez vous avez pris des
initiatives pour faire at elle pour
espionner talent et être personne ben
non on est aux ordres des politiques je
rappelle que les services de les
services sont aux ordres des politiques
les policiers les militaires
on est tous au service des politiques
donc s'il ya eu s'il ya eu un individu
seul dans son coin qui a pris
l'initiative de collaborer avec les
services secrets avec les services
américains
effectivement c'est la trahison c'est de
la trahison puisqu'il a il a outrepassé
son rôle au quotidien et en revanche
s'il ya eu un accord tacite avec entre
les deux états pour qu'il y ait juste
utilisation de ces fameux câble sans
savoir jusqu jusqu'où ça allait aller
est ce que les américains n'auraient pas
en fumée entre guillemets le les les
gallois c'est aussi possible
je sais pas j'ai pas le fin mot de
l'histoire
je n'ai pas accès a évidemment l'anc est
donc il ya deux possibilités soit ils
ont c'est une initiative de la part des
droits et ça c'est gravissime c'est
condamnable soit il y a une vraie
relation mais sans savoir jusqu'où ça
pouvait aller là aussi ils sont assez
légers dans leurs rôles dans leur
relation avec ses fans à suivre donc
merci à vous deux pierre martin et
françois un chauve en syrie d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france ce
soir